you
our lifestyle is sustained by energy yet
there are still times when we can't
access it when and where we need it but
that's about to change using electricity
is challenging because it has to be used
as soon as it's generated like when you
flip a switch on the wall there's no
local reservoir to store energy it has
to come right from the power plant if
the energy comes from wind or solar
power we will also need a way to shift
time energy storage allows us to cut the
cord and shift time just like a DVR
stores live television so you could
watch it later energy storage allows us
to store energy so we could use it there
storage may also allow us to avoid
building power plants in some locations
we additionally need to store energy in
extreme environments like inside the
body or deep in the ocean at carnegie
mellon university we're developing the
next generation of energy storage and
conversion devices like a low-cost salt
water based battery an edible battery
that can be used to power medical
devices in your body in the world's
smallest fuel cell that converts
bacteria into power it can be used deep
in the ocean at Carnegie Mellon
University Scott Institute for energy
innovation we're helping consumers and
policymakers make wise decisions based
on scientific and technical information
you can help
you